nos équipes et celles de nos partenaires
industriels sont pleinement mobilisés
pour effectuer les travaux de réparation
qui sont en cours et pour remettre sur
le réseau le maximum de réacteurs
possible pour le prochain hiver
bien sûr ces travaux de réparation
viennent accroître la charge de travail
programmé pour le grand carénage il se
pose le sujet du degré de préparation de
la filière nucléaire pour surmonter la
crise que nous traversons cette question
ce sujet m'amène à préciser certains de
mes propos récents
je viens de vous l'indiquer nous faisons
face à un cumul inattendu d'activité qui
mobilise des compétences pointues et
rares notamment celle de tuyauteur et de
soudeur mais aussi de robin étiez du
zinner de chaudronnier et d'autres
professions ce déficit de compétences
affecte notre capacité à réparer au
rythme que nous souhaiterions